I had this panel and I had parents from
around the country one from Virginia
come down to Charleston South Carolina
and she says to me I needed basically a
foia a Freedom of Information Act
request just to get a copy of my kids
curriculum I can't get into this school
and then you hear these parents in Iowa
and in Virginia who are concerned about
their kids being indoctrinated from a
gender perspective
I decided that the problems are not just
in one state they seem to be in many
states so one of the things that makes
common sense to me is the parent is the
person who should be in the biggest most
powerful position possible in making
decisions for their kids
so I want to talk about the protect kids
act because you are are leading on this
from a legislative standpoint related to
all of the gender nonsense but before
before we do that let's do one other
social justice thing according to my
notes Here uh you are black is that my
mother and grandfather have confirmed
the fact I am black
okay well but wait a minute Senator uh
according to mainstream media you can't
be black and Republican I have tried to
figure that out I looked at the polling
information and the polling suggested
there's 82 percent chance that I'm black
but the chances are 100 here's what's
happening and
this is really simple anytime an
African-American who happens to be
conservative starts making Common Sense
on TV the left must and nullify the very
existence of someone they wished was a
unicorn but I am not I am real I am not
a fairy tale I am actual really here in
front of you the truth is that the most
dangerous sight they've ever seen is
someone who actually fights for the very
people they say they represent and
produces results like opportunity zones
when you think about bringing bringing
poverty to the history of America
2019 think about the fact it is the year
that the private sector invested 29
billion dollars through opportunity
zones in those marginalized communities
leading to an eight percent increase in
wages a 20 increase in property values
which closes the it shrinks the gap
between the Haves and the have-nots and
oh by the way it led to the lowest level
ever recorded for poverty that scares
the blue Dickens out of the blue the
left it's a strange thing but it works
we have the proof is in the pudding
black conservatives that stand up for
folks living in marginalized communities
represent something that MSNBC and
sometimes CNN they just can't stomach it
but here we are they can't you know I
don't know if you know this but I
campaigned with alongside Larry Elder
when during the California recall and I
would open for him at some events and
you know I'd read the headlines and
they'd say you know all the supporters
are white supremacists and he's the
black face of white supremacy and I'm
out there in front of thousands of
people waving American flags cheering
him on and they're calling them the
white supremacists like man
here's the funny thing is here's a guy
who ran for congress in 2010 against the
sun Strom Thurmond in the birthplace of
the Civil War Charleston and because of
the evolution of the Southern heart I
sit now as a United States senator for
the great state of South Carolina if we
were talking about racist not supporting
candidates of color
I wouldn't be here nor would a
successful Wesley hunt who won his his
uh Primary in Texas by the way primaries
are typically Republican primaries are
more white than the overall population
so if you want to test the theory of
race and politics go to places like
Texas or or Charleston South Carolina or
John James in Michigan and you start
noticing there's a trend that people
actually judge you based on the content
of your character not the color of your
skin ask Myra Flores or young Kim or
Michelle Steele and you'll get the same
conclusion that Americans are far more
interested
in with on the inside than we are at the
outside but Democrats the tribal nature
of identity politics requires them to
start on the outside
and use these artif the these these
these characteristics to come to an
artificial conclusion assistant with the
very theory of progress we are the land
of opportunity we are the place where
hope breathes
Eternal do you think it's possible that
Republicans or conservatives whatever
you want to call right-leaning people
was it a was it bad messaging on that
side or was the messaging of the left
just so effective to create these untrue
uh memes that you're describing because
it's not I can tell you as someone that
was a left in my whole life came across
the aisle now and it's like I meet the
most decent loving open actually more
open-minded even than the purported
open-minded people I mean that's well
one of the things I found to be quite
interesting is the definition of any
words used in in politics today like the
inflation reduction act actually
increases inflation or the fact that you
hear people talking about the Republican
Party being a group of racists or
deplorables and the truth is when the
guy from the black lives matter a leader
showed up at the Trump rally they gave
him the stage I I mean yeah and so they
applauded him for the things that they
agreed upon and they didn't boo them
they treated him with respect and
deference on the areas of disagreement
he was stunned and obviously in my
office shook us
which would you say Tim's got internal
phrase for I can't believe that happened
so literally what we find happening all
across the country is people of good
intent they welcome debate they actually
welcome this agreement what they don't
welcome is indoctrination what they
don't welcome is you telling me that
because of the color of my skin I'm an
oppressor or you frankly telling me
because of color of my skin I'm a victim
both are offensive but people of good
intent
they don't judge you based on these
superficial things they judge you based
on how the heart responds to the crisis
of the moment all right so speaking of
the crisis of the moment let's talk
about your protect kids act I've done a
ton here on on the gender stuff
obviously all the woke stuff first off
how did this even get to your desk is
there an issue a real issue with this in
South Carolina are you just kind of
modeling this off what DeSantis is doing
down here or how did it I celebrate all
the governors around the country who
take very seriously the importance
relationship between a parent and their
teachers and Governor DeSantis has led
on this and we should give him a lot of
credit for doing so what I've seen
across the country I've I've been
focused on school choice and empowering
parents for the last nine years I I love
the model that uh Jeb Bush had and Rick
Scott had and Ron DeSantis has in in
Florida but the truth is that Governors
throughout the country including Kim
Reynolds uh in Iowa they're all all
focusing on school choice and one of the
reasons why is I had this panel and I
had parents from around the country one
from Virginia come down to Charleston
South Carolina and she says to me I
needed basically a foia a Freedom of
Information Act request just to get a
copy of my kids curriculum I can't get
into this school
and then you hear these parents in Iowa
and in Virginia who are concerned about
their kids being indoctrinated from a
gender perspective
I decided that the problems are not just
in one state they seem to be in many
states so one of the things that makes
common sense to me is the parent is the
person who should be in the biggest most
powerful position possible in making
decisions for their kids
Big labor unions and bureaucrats are in
the way of those parents making the
decisions and then working with their
teachers to carry that out I want that
to be Nationwide not in one or two
states where the governors are taking
that issue seriously every single state
when you're talking about a 12 year old
the parents should be engaged in the
decisions of their kids
that's just common sense in my house or
where I grew up I wanted to be
Communists all across the country when
you talk to the Democrats in South
Carolina and you bring this up and you
talk about transparency and okay the
power back to the parent do any of them
get it I mean again I guess it sort of
gets back to that other question we
talked about but to me something about
the one with kids maybe is a wake up
sort of like what we saw happen in
Virginia with young and winning uh when
it didn't look like he was going to win
just a couple weeks before the election
absolutely the parents do I think
parents Democrat parents get this issue
as well as Republican parents this is an
issue that actually unites parents
across the board in South Carolina they
were stunned by the developments across
the country as it relates to your
ability to have a gender identity group
and to have teachers feeling like
they're forced to provide instruction
that is just antithetical to what's in
the best interest of a child to exclude
the parent from any conversation around
those very important topics and so this
legislation would pull money away from
schools who refuse to comply with with
the law by the way of the land already
is
miners don't make decisions in a vacuum
it requires a parental supervision to
make those decisions I have to reinforce
that by pulling the money away so that
we can make them pay attention to what
the law of the land already is if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interview is on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist all
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification Bell